[Music]
sometimes I wonder if it's better to
have two dicks or one dick there's
really two Isis Isis the ice ice ice
that the public see the clowny figure
having a diarrhea every single day I'm
not gay
hmm nothing I really want to try to eat
proper good read but then there's the
ISIS ice who works harder than anyone
who's one of the best players the world
he's a prodigy as well he doesn't even
need to work hard to be amazing but he
does
there was one of the most focused and
dedicated gamers that I know right now
playing soccer up to at a professional
level he's tried League of Legends he's
done everything any after like a few
weeks he's somebody playing a
professional level he's just an
incredible eSports athlete our sign of
trouble Sun strikes here he cut goes one
will he get it off the type TV's out I
say sides fighting of solo kill and
escaping cloud I desperately need to win
this fight
display of coordination from Fiji gaming
no he well
[Applause]
[Music]
Daryll co ice ice ice patient was born
in Singapore in 1990 knew early on that
he wanted to be a professional gamer my
mom didn't really stop me from doing
anything as long as it's not illegal so
when I really wanted to stop playing
competitively in Torah or games she was
really supportive what he didn't know
was what game would be most beneficial
for him to master ice was one of those
people who couldn't touch a game without
being good at it that's very smart like
he has this ability to pick things up
very quickly maybe someone would take a
longer time to masters of the links
that's why you pay so many different
games by 2010
he'd achieved top tier results in
international Defense of the Ancients
tournaments and had cemented himself as
one of Southeast Asia's best Starcraft 2
players when I started playing Starcraft
2 it was really different because I
really wanted it the best so I had said
also trainings that I was off ways to do
with Tooting and how to improve the game
overall just write everything down and
being teacher by 2011 he played dota
Starcraft 2 league of legends and heroes
of newerth professionally I first
thought of playing dota way back during
Warcraft 3 I should please do it on like
1.0 or like 0.1 I have no idea
in preparation for Valve's first-ever
International a historic tournament
whose million dollar prize pool was then
the largest in eSports history ice ice
ice joined scythe gaming in 2011 he was
serving the OP injury the first
international but he requested
I'm off actually at 10:00 ti1
so he did actually practice much for TI
history so well and despite a
disappointing loss in a lower bracket
final scythe managed to secure a top
three finish and a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in prize winnings
but when TI 2 rolled around ice wasn't
able to replicate that success with his
new roster team Zenith classy move comes
out from Zenith as they take their exit
from the International and DK on the
back of their legend of their leader
burning is going to prolong their stay
here in Seattle for at least 24 more
hours TK a team that many thought could
peak at the right time coming into this
tournament has shown that they're able
to hang with the best of them zennith
was in the winner's bracket at the onset
of play today they fall completely out
of the tournament now come ti3 the prize
pool had reached a staggering 2.8
million dollars and ice was determined
to take home the lion's share well we
tried to prepare for the international
by playing every single day if you can
miss Tata online the past month he spent
the offseason trying to turn Zenith into
the best they could be well during
bootcamp last week there was no argument
I guess between me and X freedom I got
pretty pissed off at him for giving up
the game and I wanted to hit him so
instead of hitting him I did some stupid
anger hopping first of all I mean I'm
sure a drywall and I injured my hand
that's about it actually four days ago
yeah yeah pretty cool and for the third
year in a row
China proved too much for ice to
overcome and the GG convice calls it and
team Zenit the fans favor
home Invictus gaming stay alive and will
live to fight another day that day is
tomorrow from what I hear
despite zenus 9th 12th finish he put on
clinical performances throughout the
tournament where's that call down Isis
here
no gyrocopter just yet he's still bottom
now in comes a deputy plant a few here
of the fall
ksi driven off these there's only an
observer Ward he's gonna walk right by
crazy on the arts on aren't started
trouble son strengths here he could go
swamp really get it off the type T he's
out eyesight sides fighting of solo kill
and escaping an even bested Malaysian
legend bushi in the finals of the 1v1
competition she's gonna GG out oh my god
sighs he's here 1v1 solo champion it was
also around this time that he became
known for something else
his humor did you enjoy playing each
other was that fun you guys giving each
other looks through so I know you guys
were having a good time congratulations
it was a lot of fun to watch see in
addition to being a serious competitor
ice was also a top tier troll in fact he
was one of the dankest pranksters in all
of eSports
um are you ice ice ice uh no what's your
name
I'm not are you Michael no they're
trolling you who is trip
excuse me a second
hi how's it going
hmm hey you're pretty talkative huh
mm-hmm
well team with all he was a savage as he
was shameless how are you feeling about
the tournament so far would it what has
been the highlight for you having a
Daria every single day having a diary of
everything OD oh yeah that sounds lovely
and the community loved him for it
I want to get trolled by ice ice ice
I've been trolled by ice ice ice is
really good at it
I say it's ice she's this really good at
making situations awkward
you didn't mean diary yeah you mean
diary like he wrote your Diaries looking
like knock diarrhea Oh folks I heard him
right he knew exactly what he was doing
he knew it made me feel uncomfortable
and I respect him for that he'd also
become one of donas earliest dreaming
personalities whether it was his invoker
guides well I want angle Stella tango by
an odd angle another fluff if you want
to be dandy you can get a mentor of
intelligence that is one that he gets
but no I am NOT Dendi I'm ice ice ice
like a circular item antics
[Music]
or pogchamp plays ice was always the
Entertainer and his fans loved him for
it
we thank you Tim thank you him just like
whatever to you well I can clean as well
ah following ti3 ice decided that a
change was an order he'd spent years
watching China decimate his Southeast
Asia teams but was confident that he had
what it took to play alongside them
fortunately a legend by the name of
burning felt the same way several weeks
after TI threes all western final came
to a close ice was invited to join mushi
lam mmy and the bee God himself
on team DK the goal was simple bring
together the best players that China
Malaysia and Singapore had to offer in
an effort to bring the aegis back east
the team was already made for one reason
just for me every single time line and
in the beginning it looked promising
between TI 3 & 4 DK finished top 4 in 14
tournaments 8 of which they won they
were Bar None the best team in China
arguably the world and still all but a
handful of Chinese teams refused to
scrim them verily the streams that would
have done because the Chinese teams
generally wanna stream against us for
whatever reason
we try a lot we tried a lot of stuff or
something so we had to come to the u.s.
earlier and see you or something out
that's why we don't really have a stuff
apparently like every team except VG and
ourselves like boycott DK because like
they're not a pure Chinese team because
IG isn't obvious Chinese hero right but
they would practice with IG all of decay
so I have no idea what happened there
but um they would only practice with us
and VG I play for DK not China DK had
established themselves as one of the
strongest rosters in existence
heading into ti4 and were being touted
as odds-on favorites to win it all the
five would make team DK burning mushi
isis/isil an M and M my when they're on
fire this team they are some Watson
seemingly unstoppable but as fate would
have it they'd hit this spike during TI
for the most boring and meta abuse TI of
all time
obliterated three heroes
the top-ranked
- DJ Adia through the wagon final
they will play
and DK
Singaporeans
into the place where teams are
eliminated from the International when
nur team wants to babe
but after suffering an unexpected stop
at the hands of evil geniuses decays
confidence was shaken which became
abundantly clear in Game one of their
lower bracket doubt against LGD they
just can't keep
I cannot believe they just managed to
pull it off they shocked DK and probably
the world and they go into tomorrow up
one to nothing in the best of three
despite going on to win that series DK
looked vulnerable coming into their
semi-final match up against vici gaming
a team who perfected an almost
detestable deathball strat more point
that's going to move up and take the top
rax as well to this day team DK are
fondly remembered as one of the greatest
teams to never win
DK disbanded in August of 2014 and ice
was given a chance to join the very
roster who knocked him out of Ti a month
earlier so jolly hi Vijay at Ava's home
what now you wasn't reaching long so if
you can say Mohammed ah I got to Kabir
one beside das middle what bah
now regarded is one of the best
offlaners in the world I spent the rest
of 2014 and most of 2015 on an absolute
tear over that time vici racked up 15
top 4 placements and solidified
themselves as a stunningly consistent
roster you can't run from the black hole
the death born again from Fenrir one two
down and might even be three a GG peachy
gaming win starladder season 12
the last championship 46.83 vici gaming
they won ESL one New York they won the
summit two they placed second at DAC
they now finished first at starladder
these are all big tournaments as far as
having world-class competition this team
just has been monstrous and yet all
through it all ice never lost his
incredible uncompromising sense of humor
both in game and be good BKB TP out of
his top lane
[Laughter]
you like my plastic and out you know I
know I asked you this before but um I'm
looking you hmm
nothing carry on what what do you like
to do you know when you don't play dota
what do you do for fun it's hunger coach
oh no he likes to sing kdv drink and
sleep around that's about it like you
see like the guys this pretty pie I'll
try to read and try to mean I want to
try to read oh my life I've heard it's
good your Hut is good I heard it's good
I remember yeah like this different
kinds of read read but I really want to
try to read like proper could read but
that's what made ice such an ingenious
competitor his incessant ability to get
under the skin of those around him to
throw off his opponents to make it so
they never quite knew what he was
thinking she's creative she things out
of the box if you give him a room he
will find 100 ways to break it this is
fun if my ti5 vici were thought to be
Xuan's for a top-three finish and
despite a disastrous group stage that
set them in the lower bracket right from
the get-go they look poised for a deep
run oh well I guess in a group stages we
were sort of cocky of confidence and it
suffers right have you dropped a little
the first round of the losers bracket so
I guess because we dropped into the
first round reserves back here we are
climbing up pretty well that is until
they faced off against China's other
perennial powerhouse LGD Fiji danger
Pete eliminated and denied what could
have been a huge match vs EG
Gidi they can smell it they can taste it
this game is in their hands and they now
lead by 20,000 gold close to 30,000
again surprise
vici gaming tapped out at at LGD who
hate on the streak and tear feet she
gave me were undefeated command in the
series they won that game one but it's
LGD to take it after that VG's results
tapered off they achieved a top six
finish at the Frankfurt major but came
in dead last at the Shanghai major it
was clear that Bee Gees era had come to
an end
within a month ice had joined the ranks
of yet another story Chinese org hee-ho
Dasha will join passion you go on the
line Siwon my pile of iron lay down the
conveyer 2016 was a challenging year for
ice he homes results were a far cry from
the ones he had become accustomed to and
he was forced to make several positional
changes as a result and right now I'm
playing positional fall for you
once di itself rolled around something
happened
eHome went on an absolute tear they
racked up win after win after win they
found a car accident between FAS who
should be a flight rule and everything
just worked out really well after
crushing alliance in the first round of
the upper bracket a home were given the
unenviable task of dethroning evil
geniuses the tournament's defending
champions
JT is the
day two is cut short down but not out
eHome looked to initiate their lower
bracket climb by defeating digital chaos
a band of Western misfits who cinderella
story had become the tournament's
central storyline once again ice had
fallen on the wrong side of fate fall
owing ti6
ice returned to Singapore he'd spent
three years abroad and after failing to
win TI with just as many dominant
chinese rosters he decided to go back to
his roots from this point on I started
prioritizing his personal life over his
competitive career he started by
focusing on his own Southeast Asian
roster team faceless whose gaming house
was the first in Singaporean history we
thought I had I did I fell at him yeah
we are gonna do it like last year but I
thought of let him alone because I
wanted to play with my team won like for
another year and every year some
addition unlike the tier 1 orgs under
which ice had previously played faceless
was a grassroots operation still they'd
amassed a dedicated following one who
wasn't deterred by the team's
international mediocrity it'll help but
not as much as something wasn't
something did not appeal to him at all
and by mid 2017 those fans were rewarded
oh gee but in spite of the momentum they
built Ison Co stumbled ahead of dota
twos biggest tournament they did it once
before they were forced to go into a
tiebreaker Wow
and they're looking to do it once again
fortress is gone game is after failing
to qualify for TI for the first time in
his professional career ice left
faceless for a more established
Southeast Asian roster Mineski he also
made his long-awaited return to the
streaming world and brought his
household with him from his wife
pestering him off-screen do i watch pond
with my wife no I don't don't
you know you go to his baby puking all
over his lap Isis dream somehow rode the
line between wholesome family fun and
well philosophizing about dicks like all
the time sometimes I wonder if he's
better than boutiques or one dick I'm
pretty sure like having three dicks is
not good but two - you know if
positioned correctly you can actually do
a lot you know actually try measuring my
size of my dick before it's not huge but
I think it's an average size acceptable
despite becoming one of the most
celebrated streamers and dota ice wasn't
without his controversy in April of 2018
he was issued a one-month banned from
twitch after using a racial slur on
stream prompting mineski to release an
apology on his behalf mineski quickly
established themselves as one of the
strongest squads in the southeast the
issue is that they struggled to perform
internationally they crushed qualifiers
put up excellent results at lesser
tournaments but crumbled at the ones
that mattered the buzz charts download
but Reza just stands his ground with the
matter with the BKB looking at the
ancient takes it down the game is over
Yugi will win the series two to one
despite mineski best efforts there with
everything against the woman but come
DAC 2018 they managed to flip the script
mineski legends they absolutely are
mushi rips through LGD the edge you
won't fool
Mineski yo 2018 DAC major champions
it was here surrounded by his kinsmen
that ice helped mineski become the first
Southeast Asian team to ever win a major
and instead of popping off ice walked
out onto that stage and well did ice
thing but at the end of the day that's
who ice is someone who accepts wins and
losses with grace humility and a healthy
dose of humor someone who's so invested
in his professional career that if he
ventured to take it seriously for even a
second it might be too much for him to
handle seriously while you're doing this
I mean it it makes me comfortable and
when I'm comfortable I play my best it's
been six years since ti2 I've lost six
[ __ ] T eyes
Big Bear makes me myself but the pun and
I want to play my best mineski went on
to put up top six finishes at epicenter
at the MDL major and ESL one Birmingham
going into TI 8 they represented one of
the best hopes Southeast Asia had at
claiming the ages
[Applause]
[Applause]
we'll move on another TI and another
year that ice would walk away
empty-handed but as the community would
glean from Isis heartwarming exit
interview that was okay like I've been
trying really hard got a fake but yeah
no noise watering at me so yeah I think
we are still gonna they're gonna talk it
out and we know what's gonna happen
after day after ta did you just use a
loser interview to ask for an artifact
key well that's a fast he went on to
join fnatic and qualify for TI 9 as the
seventh seed in the 2018-19 dota pro
circuit once again ice had grinded his
way to the biggest stage in dota ice ice
ice is trying to get his 80th career win
on timbersaw
79 and 41 that is 50 more wins than the
next closest player for his career the
TI 7 champions against third place
stockholm major finishers fnatic with
everything on the line unfortunately it
just wasn't his year and with that Team
Liquid are moving on fnatic out of TI 9
despite suffering a first round
elimination at the hands of liquid it
became clear that ice was as content as
ever with this station in life all right
do you have anything to say to your fans
you've got a lot of fans in all
different regions what do you want to
say to them be happy yeah I mean life
good you I did and honestly at this
point it doesn't really matter if he
wins a TI he's had a great run one of
the greatest careers of any dota player
ever and hasn't regretted a second of it
ice is among the first generation of
players to leverage the so-called
esports life into a real one to reach
the point where he could stop look
around and truly appreciate what
dedicating himself to the game he loves
has given him I'm sort of a gamer since
I was a kid
so retiring isn't really a word for me
it's like does exist I mean you like
games are just gonna keep playing
I mean I'm gonna play every single game
that is out there I mean yeah why why
why would you retire it's just it's how
you don't be tired from eating after
you're done eating but just gonna eat
again however and whenever his career
comes to an end he'll always be
remembered for his elegance creativity
and eccentricity I mean it's fine we're
trying to get used to drinking coffee
tea and doing coke
I mean drinking coke we're always
prioritizing the journey over the
endpoint the joy of playing over the
need to win for just being Darryl thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]